and tell me this when you went i think
the the first time you went
was it to do a tv show 1967 or something
45
65. and is that when you met elvis for
the first time i met elvis presley
i was there don't try and compete
so i uh i got there and um you know it
was wonderful we were staying in the
jean autry hotel
you know on sunset strip at the time and
do you know what he was there saw him
standing there you know
i mean god you know this is unbelievable
my first year in show business
and then i had to go to paramount
studios for the song for something
and they said uh elvis presley's going
to be there tomorrow
and he would like to meet you i thought
elvis presley wants to meet me
it was unbelievable and i went there and
and you know to go and see about this
song and they said elvis is filming
and um you know once once they stop the
filming
you go in so i did and then i'm they
closed the doors again and i'm standing
in the back there with the memphis mafia
these guys that work for him and he's in
this little mock helicopter with this
girl
and um and they did a scene you know and
i'm like look at my goddess alves
presley
and then he they said okay cut and he
looked across and went
you know and i was like you know looking
at these fellas who will be they said
elvis is waving at you don't wave back
so anyway so he gets out of this
helicopter and he starts walking towards
me
well i had a single record out at the
moment it was my
third single uh called with these hands
it was a ballad it's a beautiful song
and elvis is walking towards me going
with his hand oh my god i will cling to
you
right and he's going and i thought my
god if the boys back home could see me
now
you know
that's amazing story